We are a tag team and perhaps we need to be because this is
a controversial subject. And I come to you as an academic
and I realize that that term has been used somewhat
pejoratively a few times today. Rather than talk about
theory I want to talk about common sense and start out with
what we know and what do we know. Well we know that prudent
and sensible banker does not loan someone $970,000 to buy a
million dollar house. I think we can all agree on that. We
also know that if that person who is buying the house says
but Mr. Banker you must allow me to put down only 30000
since that is the only way I can get the ROE made Return on
Equity that I need on my investment. We know that the banker
is going to say no. What else do we know? I think it was
pretty well rehearsed today. We know that in 2007 we had a
very highly leveraged very fragile financial sector. It was
basically 30000 down on a million dollar house. Now of
course we were told and we actually assume perhaps that the
situation was not the same as a highly leveraged house
because banks and others had accurate risk models in
effective ways to control risk, but we also know what
happened.
So let me ask the question: would the situation have been
less dire had the financial sector been much less leveraged
and I assert to you that that is basically a rhetorical
question. It's not our position that high equity, low
leverage sounds everything but I think we can all agree that
this situation would have played out very differently. And
in fact this was what was eluded to before we can look back
in history and we can see times when the bank sector was
much less highly leveraged, much more equity and things
still seem to function, which leads you to question why don'
t we have more equity and we have talked in various ways
today about some of the advantages of having much greater
equity. The go-down payments you might say. Systematic risk,
if certainly reduced, there is less chance of financial
crisis and the deadweight losses and we never should forget
the deadweight losses that are associated with the financial
crisis which Daily Miles quantified in various ways here.
Risk is privatized. We talked about the importance of having
the market basically governing how things are done rather
than leaving it to regulators. Well to the extent that
insurance is being provided here it's by equity, not by the
government and so we can say that this is moving in the
direction that Kevin Warsh and others were saying of having
the market do it rather than the government. And the
incentives to take socially unproductive risk are clearly
reduced at the margin if we increase equity. So social
benefits are quite large, which of course leads to the
question why is there a controversy here, why are we up here
because if equity has so much to offer in terms of the
social benefits why don't we see more people calling for,
why is there such resistance. And of course the resistance
is that it's expensive. Is it really expensive, that's the
question we want to ask.
And it's very, very, very important I put three verys in
there to distinguish between private and social and we have
sort of talked around the margins on this. Well let's be
very clear. What are the private cost to have more equity?
Well the tax code, basically disfavors equity favors debt
financing. There is no doubt about that. The government
makes debt cheap through implicit guarantees, the two big
failed subsidies perhaps under priced deposit insurance,
various things of that sort that favors debt over equity.
And increasing equity as we will see it little bit later
when Peter talks mechanically reduces ROE and also reduces
risk but if compensation is somehow tight, somewhat rigidly
to ROE, this potentially can reduce someone's pay which gets
certain people's attention. What is the social cost, that's
the real question here? And that's a big question mark. Let'
s talk about a little bit more about these incentives. There
is a too-big-to-fail subsidy that we have talked about and
if a bank believes if the investors in the bank specifically
the creditors believe that there is some potential for the
government to come in and give support that's going to lower
the required yield on that debt.
And you can do a very simple calculation to show that this
is a nontrivial effect. For instance if we just reduce the
average cost of liabilities by 2.5 basis points we are
building 3% equity that's a 1% increase in ROE. If we
increase or decrease that cost by 10 basis points again
that's not all that much we get a 3% increase in ROE. So
this definitely creates some incentives. Now is this
hypothetical, is this academic theory? No, even Moody says
we talked earlier recognizes this and in fact gives two
different ratings - one based upon government support and
one is a standalone. So let's talk about the incentives in
banking very quickly. I am going to simplify banking a
little bit here but not much, it's a spread business. You
will receive interest and then you pay interest but bankers
if they get this subsidy aren't really paying all the
interests that they should. So I think that subsidy is
basically given by the government that comes in the form of
less interest paid. And that's a minus to all of us in the
room that aren't bankers.
And then of course we pay taxes, all of us, including the
banks but that's a benefit to the government. There is a
question as to what's done with it. Now we divide this by
equity we get required rate of Return on Equity or the
Return on Equity here. And now let's look at what the
incentives are. By taking that equity and making it smaller
what happens? Well the first thing is I will pay a little
bit more interest but that's increasing the subsidy and I
will pay less taxes. So the bank is going to have a higher
numerator here. The government has clearly lost it's minus
the subsidies plus the taxes both of those have gone down.
And now we are dividing by a smaller number there and the
denominator that's going to make for higher ROE. So the
incentives are very clear but let me also be very clear,
just because bankers have an incentive to argue for
economizing on equity for the very clear reasons that we
just saw, that doesn't mean that they are wrong when they
say that equity might be expensive but it does mean very
strongly that we should be skeptical and we should demand
that they support their claims with sound arguments.
Now one thing that might be asserted is yes there are these
subsidies but these subsidies are important because they do
beneficial things and they pass on some of these subsidies
to those who are borrowing. Let's think about that just a
little bit more. If we are basically giving tax in implicit
government subsidies that are creating incentive for
leverage and high leverage that's bad because that creates
the systematic risk that we are all trying to avoid. And the
question really is at the end of the day does that really
lead to better loans and if it does let's do it directly,
not to a mechanism that creates problems. So the big
question here which we are going to look at in a little bit
more detail here is are there social costs to bank equity.
Now we started out looking at private costs but no, that's
not what we should look at. We should look at the social
cost and be mindful of the social benefits that are very
large and now there is a question as to what these social
costs are. So what we are going to now do is turn to a very
skeptical appraisal of the arguments that have been put
forward for saying that that question right there is
positive and large. I have made a small but I don't want to
prejudge things here is Peter.
Peter: Thanks Paul and so obviously we were thinking about
today the tradeoff between capital requirements which we
have many have argued today it will reduce the probability
of financial crisis. On the other hand there is the issue of
confidential higher borrowing cost and if that will slow
economic growth. And so the real question is how do we trade
those off. We have seen some analysis today, here are some
discussions about it. And what we are trying to do in our
discussion is define that debate and get us to focus on what
the key issues are. Obviously we have heard a lot today
about the increase in leverage that lead to the financial
crisis and we think about sort of these deleveraging spirals
that result from leverage if we have 3% equity and 1% the
client in asset value means that 30% reduction contraction
of potential balance sheet contraction if we try to
recapitalize without raising new funds and so we get the
problem of asset fire sales and liquidity market failure on
certain key bailout follow-up things that we observed in the
crisis.
And so the question is can we address that with more capital
is that a tool that regulator should feel confident
utilizing in this context. And we are going back to David
Vineyard's point this morning where he argued that liquidity
is costly to maintain but even more constantly if not
maintained. I would say the same is true for capital in
terms of the benefit of maintaining capital is quite high
and probably even higher given that capital adequacy and
solvency is a precursor to liquidity and yet I will argue
that the costs are actually lower for maintaining adequate
capital than for liquidity per se. But we know that there is
some cost for maintaining liquidity. For capital our
argument is very different and that's an important that we
think we would like regulators to understand in terms of
being more flexible in their use of capital as a mechanism
to increase safety in the banking sector.
So the question is equity too expensive and what I want to
talk about in my section is sort of what are some of the
arguments that have been used that you hear about why
acquisition bank is expensive while we don't think there are
right arguments and why our kind of question to
practitioners who are concerned about these requirements is
let's dig deeper into what might be the real cost because
the ones that are pre-forth don't seem like the correct one.
So first confusion so we are crowding out concern that
increased capital requirements will force banks to reduce
lending simply because it means they have to set aside some
assets.
And of course that's not what capital requirements are
about, it's not about setting aside any assets at the
funding issue and it's about leverage so it's really
question of capital structure. So the idea of holding
capital is expensive is sort of a misnomer since we are not
holding anything per se. It's not a question about how we
allocate assets.
In terms of increasing capital there are different ways we
can do that but importantly there is no mechanical
requirement that we reduce lending through increased capital
requirements. Of course that's one way it can happen if I
want to double the amount of capital that bank has. One way
to do it is to contract the assets and move from 10%
capital, 20% capital in that way. But an alternative way to
do that is we could simply recapitalize some of the
liabilities through an increased inequity. And we might
argue well we don't necessarily want do that because some of
these liabilities like deposits are important as for the
value creation of the banking system and services it
provides. Well there is still a third way we can do which is
an asset expansion, right we could simply raise new equity,
put new assets on the balance sheet, a third way to do that.
So there is no mechanical reason sometimes argued that an
increase in equity requirements are going to lead to a
reduction in lending. Now of course we would say well it's
about the cost of these three different alternatives and
there is some reason to think that banks might be pushed
towards the former versus the latter in terms of raising new
equity, real benefit creditors. And it will help creditors
and therefore recast that to every holder. And so one of the
things from a regulatory standpoint to think about is either
ways we can provide mechanisms that push banks in this
direction versus this direction of course helping creditors
is a way of attempting to get banks to pay for the cost of
the risk they are taking as opposed to leaving it for
government bailouts and other subsidies from that point.
So that's one thing to think about and one of the proposals
on these lines is to suggest that we get banks to increase
capital by looking at lagged asset base as opposed to
allowing them to do it by asset contraction. It's certainly
something to think about. But the key point is there is no
mechanical need for increase in capital to lead to a
reduction in lending.
The second point is lower ROE which we heard, discussed this
morning that is a concern that you will hear from the banks
that it's going to lower the returns to equity holders and
that statement is partially true but the point is that low
ROE does not reduce firm value, doesn't necessarily reduce
firm value and that lower expected ROE is appropriate given
the reduced risk with higher capital requirements. And in
particular if we just look at what happens to ROE comparing
a 10% capital with 20% capital it's true that ROE is lower
in good times with a high capital but it's higher in bad
times, right that capital providing that buffer in bad
times.
And so what we are sort of giving up in a sense up here for
shareholders we are gaining down here and that if things are
fairly priced and ignoring imperfections in the market these
two should be equivalent in value terms from a shareholder's
perspective. And so it doesn't reduce shareholder value per
se. Now of course if the downside is already being if equity
holders are not, don't need to worry about that downside
because of other projections for government guarantees then
they are arguing up subsidies again in this tradeoff and
that would be an example of private incentive and not
wanting to increase capital as we spoke of earlier.
Performance evaluation, another issue obviously we think
about ROE and I want to give another example of why ROE isn'
t really a very good measure to think about the value
created via the banks. We think of a manager, a fund manager
with a 22% return and the one with a 20% return and who
deserves higher compensation. Well obviously it's not enough
information especially if I told you that the first one was
taking a much riskier strategy and had much fewer assets
under management.
The point is that when we think about returns we really need
to think about risk adjusted value added so the alpha
generated time the assets under management or kind of
translate in the banking context we want to think about
excess ROE above what's a fairer risk adjusted return given
the risk they are taking times the amount of equity based
that that's on and that measure is going to be invariant to
leverage, again apps and other frictions and so forth. So
looking at ROE per se isn't really the right measure if we
want to think about value added.
The third point on equity is expensive is simply that equity
capital is much more costly so we got to increase the amount
of equity capital that's going to raise the cost of doing
business and that's going to be transferred to borrowers.
And we heard this morning the cost of equity is a step
function or might not move as we increase capital. And
really these arguments ignore the fact that we know the cost
of equity will decline with higher capital and reduced risk
offsetting entire cost. There is a fair amount of evidence
for that empirical evidence it's also the basis of most
models that the banks themselves use when thinking about a
variety of products that they go ahead and market. So well
that's got to be the case and so we really have to be
arguing something about equity investors being irrational or
there being some other supply constraints or other factors
in the market.
So I want to kind of just do a simple thought experiment
here. We have got assets and liabilities you think of the
asset side as sort of value creation unlike most standard
industrial firms so value creation also happens on the
liability side for banks in terms of deposits, deposit
taking and transaction services and so forth. So we want to
think of some of this as part of the underlying business of
the bank. But there is a fair amount that's just of the
funding piece and when I think about what happens if we
separate some of that and we take some of that funding and
replace it rather than being highly leveraged equity in
place. And the point of course is then in the rational
market the cost of this larger equity piece should be the
blended cost of an equity that we had before. This would be
again just a standard argument we would be making any sort
of portfolio analysis.
And therefore that it shouldn't raise the weighted average
cost of capital for the bank. That shareholder should
understand this. If they don't then something must be
fundamentally wrong in the market. Again, either there is
some irrationality or supply constraints or other factors.
Now if you like one thing you could think about is well
suppose we did that and suppose we were concerned that this
cost of equity reduction would not occur, one could think
about separating the leverage kind of from the bank entity
itself so we could imagine taking this equity, pulling it
and then creating products that replicate these payoffs that
could be sold to investors but separate from the bank
activity itself. So even if there are ultimately losses on
some of these products to equity link type products they
don't put the bank in any sort of the stress. So we could
imagine separating those and the real question is what is
the cost from doing this in fact this might be even more
flexible in terms of if investors prefer more leverage or
less leverage we could get the optimal mix determines
separately from the bank's activity itself.
So that's, let me leave it there and turn over
[inaudible] I think the key questions are we talked about
taxes and government guarantees as private benefits and to
the banking sector but not about social benefits. We talked
about some of the key arguments that you hear for a why
equity is costly and said that they don't really hold up so
the key question I think for practitioners and for the
researchers think about well if there are costs what are
they and let's get down and define it precisely so we can
measure them and so we can make sure whatever policy
prescriptions we have are directed towards what those true
costs are.
[Informal Talk]
So the key question that we have here is high leverage
somehow a function that's something inherent in the banking.
This comes with the territory of banking and got to there
because that's the way it is, it's a debt business, it's a
spread business, it's a leverage business. Our answer to
this question is that we have looked at all of the arguments
that were made and actually some that are not yet in our
paper that are also made. And so far in about a year or more
looking at it we actually have not found anything that would
convince us that high leverage is necessary for banks to
function.
It is true that some debts of the bank as was mentioned is
part of their business but that is not the same. The amount
of debt is not the same as the amount of leverage. So it
incurred about large social cost and we do not see any
benefit from the high leverage socially. Everything about
the value the banks create can be done with less leverage.
There is absolutely nothing we can see in the economics of
it that would tell you that 25% equity on total balance
sheet should be unthinkable for banks. If somebody thinks
that that is a terrible-horrible thing we haven't seen why
yet. In particular this balance sheet C if you were to think
about and I do not mean to suggest that bank should grow
even larger this is just a way to think about this because I
think once they have more equity funding we will see the
natural size of the banking sector and of individual banks
more organically is whether adding equity is somehow
expensive and in what sense is it expensive. In fact, I
would argue, we argue that it's not only not expensive, it's
a social bargain, only good things happen when you do that
for what anyway. In other words, as far as I can see from
where we are right now or we can see it's a benefit to
increasing equity, we do not see cost, certainly not high
cost. But we didn't say our equity is not costly, we say it'
s not expensive, expensive is in different means, expensive.
So you could say that we need safety net expansion and I
think we already agreed on this form that that is not a good
thing. The safety net was created to prevent inefficient
bank run in FDIC before that, by the way, banks had in the
US not even limited liability. So banks in the US until the
1930s-40s in many states, I had double triple and unlimited
liability and the liability is the downside of the note
every time was warned by equity, except that in the question
there was a lot of personal bankruptcy and it was decided
there were a lot of inefficient runs and when banks were
very small and not diversified there were runs, even though
there was a lot of equity. So it's not like there were runs
for different reasons and so we have got a better system and
the system has become more leveraged as we saw. But the
safety net has expanded as a bank of
[inaudible] has shown and the question is whether we have
sort of too much of it.
So to expand it, without giving a free gift to the bank is
to charge for it which would mean some kind of a bailout
fund but that's very, very difficult to price and already
FDIC is hard enough to price. So it's not, if we can avoid
it, that's not the way to just insure everything. It would
be very hard and
[inaudible] is always there because there is always basics
that are trying to take advantage of those guarantees. So we
do not recommend that if it's possible to create a little
more self-insurance and self-insurance is precisely equity.
Equity means that the private sector bears a lot more of the
downside and so it's a question of whether their economies
can spend that, can stand to have 20% of risk capital in
economy a backup of the bank's liability instead of some
other system.
We have their presentation about loss absorbing debt and
this is sometimes people think of contingent capital and
bail-enabled debt as a substitute for equity. We believe
that it's a poor substitute. In the crisis, no hybrid
suffered any losses. The idea here is to conserve on equity
and since we do not believe equity is expensive, we do not
see a reason to conserve on equity and create magical
complicated ways to get the debt, to become equity because
then we have to ask why it was debt in the first place which
is like long-term debt or others, why was it issued as debt
to begin with. What was it doing as a debt because it's not
the secure debt, it's not the deposits that are going to be
inflicted that there is unsecured subordinated debt, why is
it there instead of being equity so I am going to ask that
question.
Bail-in is of course sort of can be thought of as part of
resolution and as a way to sort of preempt the bankruptcy,
the laws of the bankruptcy what happens when you default.
And obviously, we want a better system than bankruptcy laws
so I completely agree with that. And in that context,
obviously, we should be thinking about whatever we can do
across countries and all these things. But it is not a
substitute for pushing equity requirements way higher and we
would even say way higher than David Mild's recommend.
And so why bankers agree for to cocos? Well, Barclays told
us they want cocos so that their ROE will not be affected,
that is not a valid reason. Taking advantage of taxes, tax
subsidies to the extent it is tax deductible is also not a
social cost as we explained. So our feel is that if you
compare if whatever you were going to make contingent
capital at that time that you issue it as contingent
capital, you instead make it equity. Then when the assets go
down, obviously, we don't want bailout so none of us kind of
want that. If contingent capital was going to bring the
equity that you need, if it was issued as equity, you would
also have it there. So it's not about recapitalization it's
about capitalization. So whatever contingent capital was
going to do for you, equity can do for you and somebody is
going to have to explain why contingent capital then is not
better than debt but why it's better than equity.
There are other things that are said some of them are
academics. They are not logical policies or confusions
between private and social costs and benefits. But we have
theories that say debt contracts have discipline. Well,
discipline as we already heard does not work when there is a
bailout. So anything that guaranteed is not going to do any
discipline for you, we can agree on that. The threat to run
is not going to discipline when it's not a credible threat,
the threat to default doesn't do anything, if there is a
bailout or if you can recapitalize immediately so there
needs to be a real threat there and it's not there. And the
question also is even if you were to say that debt can
discipline and debt does discipline in many models which
explains why the bank itself does not take equity position
in the small businesses that it runs so debt is an optimal
contract for pay me and then I wanted to worry about it
until you don't pay me and then I will worry about it at a
cost. So that's kind of optimal contracting for small people
but not for the banks necessarily.
Even if it was providing some discipline the question is do
we need it at the cost, at the social cost that it involves?
Can we do governance and how do other companies in the
economy do their governing when they have 80%, 90%, 100%
equity? How do they actually discipline their managers? Do
they need high leverage and if they don't and if they choose
not to then how do they do it and can banks also do it? Can
they get a better contract with the managers, can they get
the managers preferred, can they do anything that would not
create this cost on the economy?
So then people talk about assurance costs. Here there are
two parts to it, one is the sort of we have buzzword for it,
it's call Myers and Majluf, it's an insurance cost about the
sigma associated with issuing equity or withholding
dividends and yes, but that is not a reason to not move from
the level of capital that we have now to another level. That
is more of a transition thing, but once you are there, any
friction of this sort you have is actually lower. So
whatever you are talking about being at 5% versus being at
20% equity is better even on that front because you have
left need to erase equities so you are not in the market as
much because you have retained earnings as a view. And this
sigma also is not a social cost and can be in helped by
removing discussion which was already mentioned here, so
that there was no sigma. Just like thought was given to
banks in sitting in a room and not allowed to spook anybody
by taking or not taking the money.
The big picture, if you want to look at the big picture is
it's sort of a big picture of balance sheet scene and the
big picture says when people ask where is all this equity
going to come from? Well, equity comes from end investors in
the end for the entire economy. So if you look at the big
picture here, then what we have in one case of highly
leveraged banks is we have three kinds of assets, some
assets are held directly, that's class B.
[Informal Talk]
So in here we have a highly leveraged bank or banking system
and some of the assets in the economy are held through that,
some are held directly, some are held through other
intermediaries. Now if I move to my balance sheet seesaw it
didn't touch whatever the bank is doing, I didn't touch all
the loans that are wonderful and I didn't touch all the
deposits that everybody needs for liquidity or other things
that are there. I didn't touch. I just did my balance sheet
fee just for their sake of showing you that I don't need to
touch anything in the economy. I am only regrouping claims
in the economy. So in this balance sheet, right in this
picture right here, A, B and C are still there and I don't
even mind if the banks have more assets in the economy. Let
them buy more stuff and back up their liabilities.
It aligns something better when that happens so even if you
were to tell me theoretically and I don't believe that they
will grow this way but I will even say I don't care if they
go as long as it's with equity then nothing really
productive changes in the economy and because end investors
didn't hold everything that they held before. It is the case
though that if the government was going to bail out these
banks then it's not bailing as much out these banks over
here. But we think there is capacity to move to there.
Okay so basically more equity has benefits because highly
leveraged firms in general, but especially, highly leveraged
firm that have implicit guarantees have incentives that
explicitly works. This is a problem that basically makes
firms stay away from high leverage because that will
recognize that they will end up taking, such a person will
require a return for that or will he require a lot of
covenants to protect from that. So that in all companies is
going to become a little onerous on the firm which why many
firms don't want to leverage. But the bank debt holders do
not impose such covenants and other things.
The big other issue hanging here is that over hang, and this
is a reason actually that banks are really reluctant or
unable to raise funds or unwilling to raise funds for new
loans when they already have highly leveraged. So when you
have a lot of debts already in place, you are impaired in
functioning. And that is the reason that we had a credit
freeze. The reason for credit reduction is not too much
equity, it's too much debt and I will talk some more about
lending if I have the time.
We have level playing field up ahead with one of my
coauthors about this, so one has to think about who is
backing up. As long as there are no subsidies, it's good to
have competition. The unregulated shadows, is basically not
an argument for anything because we had shadow banking with
the low capital requirements. So if we want to flow our
hands in the air, and say we can't enforce anything, that we
might as well no tax because of tax loopholes. In other
words that's just a defeatist argument, can you or can't you
regulate, is the question to that, that there would be
enforcement issues as clear with any regulation. And there
were enforcement issues before. So it's not like this
problem is going to be new or necessarily worth because it's
always going to be there. It's the same problem with low and
high capital requirements you need to figure out how to do
it.
And it's kind of not, it's an enforcement issue and it is a
challenge to enforce these regulations. But we just have to
figure out what we want to do. And then we have to try to
challenge it. Will there be, might there be a lending order
of contraction, if you really think about this question.
There is, first of all the possibility, just the possibility
that it actually is not true. These great loans are going to
lie there and not being taken. Well in New York these days,
it's my co-lenders that lend because banks kind of don't
feel like it's too much work to check credit worthiness it
seems. But in the Option expensing Debate we heard that the
economy will shrink and that didn't happen when options
became expense, so just because people said something doesn'
t necessarily make it true. But if you think about whether
credit will go down, well may be some credit should go down.
We think we have a credit bubble and we can do too much
lending. So not all lending is good lending, we want good
lending, not just any lending.
So if some lending doesn't happen then might be just as
well. We don't know what the two economic costs should be.
The risk rate gives distorted incentives. This is, it was
discussed at lunch time and one of my coauthors is very
strong and strongly disillusioned with risk rates. So
Raphael presented the view, the risk rates could be
distorted and one of the immediate ways to satisfy capital
requirements based on risk weighted assets to move to low
risk weighted assets. I would only point out about risk
weights that Greek Sovereign that has zero risk weight and
pays 20% right now. And that sort of rests the case and AAA
Securities also has zero risk rates and turnout to be quite
systemic. So risk rates do not give you a measure and we
already had that covered.
The debt overhang itself where we are right now would make
you not lend. And so that by itself is because we are
already in a bad place and not because of where we want to
go. Where we want to go is to be in a place where there won'
t be as much of that. If lending spreadsheet increase may be
because of the subsidies that are removed and that there
would be some little bit of a margin there, but it depends
what we want to subsidize, do we want to subsidize lending
or do we want to subsidize the leverage of the banks so that
they can pass it on somehow, it's very inefficient way.
So the summary is that we do not have numbers, okay, people
press us on the numbers because we don't begin to have an
economic theory of the costs where we are right now. So
David presented some cost, so we can argue even with David
on exactly what those costs are. But we look at the recent
30%. We just don't see where the costs come in. I don't see
the big as Debbie pointed out miles, it's not clear, it's
debt sensitive once you get to it. So it's not going to be a
decimal point because I cannot even quantify some of these
other benefits that I see, and the costs that I can barely
find, so it's going to be very hard to make any kind of on
the same scale, from where we are right now or even from
Basel.
Requirements should not be one number, I want to mention
that because the best line on this is that the child's good
hard line on the taxi cab in the station. So if you have
regulation that says if there should be a taxi cab waiting
at the train station at all times then when you get to the
train station at 2 in the morning the taxi cab cannot take
you because then there won't be a taxi cab in the train
station. So the capital requirements cannot be one number
and we see what happens when people just be leveraged to a
number, where you need to draw down on it, you must have a
range. So the buffer in Basel in principle is a big
breakthrough and it is a good thing. There has to be a
range, but the range, and within their range what Basel does
is it restricts bid and which is exactly the kind of sort of
graduated responses that you want to have, is sort of to
kind of stop capital from leaking out which we unfortunately
allow it to happen through the crisis. And then maintain the
leverage that its regulators have which is equity insurance
and equity payouts.
In particular through transition all you need to say and
then you can't even tell me about issuance cost is we are
paying earning. Now in other words allowing banks to pay
dividends was extremely offensive to some of us. That's it,
you can see the paper and some other writings in this
website. We had copies of some things out there. And I guess
we will answer questions. I am the last so, but any one will
answer question if there are any.
[Informal Talk]
Question: Could you elaborate on the point of having a ratio
that's completely risk insensitive because I see a problem
both ways? Basel I was risk insensitive and it led to
regulatory arbitrage because if bank was told to hold the
same capital for a loan to a AAA firm as to anon-investment
grade firm it led to all sorts of consequences but the
converse is if you do have risk sensitivity your argument
would seem to imply. It doesn't matter if risk measure or
wrong because banks should be indifferent to how much
capital they hold and that seems very paradoxical.
No, no, no, not banks but society. Banks will not like it,
but I am talking about regulators. With the vision that we
have, the vision that we describe is certainly your company
you write, I mean capital does not mean anything except for
the risk. And if you have all treasuries in your assets then
my capital requirements are not, they don't need to be high.
So clearly it has to be a function of debt. The image that
we have on capital requirements is that of a margin
requirement and exchange. We have in mind this smart
regulated, instead of what Erwin wants them to do, which is
to know when that point is, when a complicated bank is
insolvent and just be there overnight to transform its
balance sheet or when 15 banks are doing that we want the
regulators in healthy times to monitor just like an exchange
does for marginal cost, and to hold their hands on leverage,
to monitor the systemic risk, more than even the individual
risk because may be some firms should be allowed to fail and
then adjust the capital requirements to the risks. So when I
said 30% I mean like for example relative to current assets
I don't know. We have to work on that, so I don't know.
Question: I am with JP. Morgan and bank of our size, if we
were to follow your prescription round numbers here, we
would have to raise $350 billion equity. So what my first
question is, will you come back to New York with me and work
on the press release. So I booked the meeting with my
chairman to say that he should issue something.
Sure, I want all of the banks to do this over time. So you
should pay the dividend, that's the first thing.
Question: Okay, I predict the meeting wouldn't go too well.
Second question, why not go to a 100%, I am not sure I got
that, should we go all the way to 100%?
I said I am going to leave all these deposits there, I am
leaving the function of banking, I just don't want, I want
to backup, they would have liabilities because liability is
part of their business. So Apple doesn't have that as part
of their business, but banks do. I want to backup their
liabilities more than it's backed up by now, that's what I
want. I think some of the backing, some of the liabilities
are not essential to their business, long term debt is not
essential to banking business, nobody is going to tell me
why they need long term debt investment-
We are not advocating a 100% equity, clearly that's pushing
into direction of reductio ad absurdum. What we are doing is
we are starting right now and we are saying and it's really
what David Mile said, and we are backing up by just some
clear headed thinking about it in the sense of, if we push
equity more and it may take a little bit time to get $300
billion more in equity, we understand that. But if you keep
equity more, and point that you can do is not said is not
pay dividends for a while, but if you basically push more
and have a bigger equity question as Peter has explained
that's not going to change your cost of funding. You may
believe that. It's only going to change your cost of the
funding to the extent that it takes away tax advantages,
which we really should work to neutralize.
And I realize a lot of us would like to just say we can't
bid over the tax code, the tax code is what it is, but that'
s too easy. In other words, if we are really creating
problems because we are unwilling to change the tax code,
that's a real problem. So let's basically take away the
subsidies, take away the tax code, push it into direction of
having self-insurance, by people out there, it should be
self-insuring you and me, not through the tax systems but
through holding equity in banks.
And go to very comfortable point where we know that we have
got enough to basically survive the type of thing that we
saw in 2007 and 2008. Your bank did better than others so
may be it's unfair that you are coming under this, but we
know that some other banks didn't do that well. And we have
to make it safe for the entire sector and as a first order
effect having a lot more equity, not going to 100% but
getting may be 10% or 15%, is going to be a huge benefit and
the costs are just private cost and we should figure out how
to basically take those away, so that the right decisions
get made on an economic basis.
Question: So Paul, I think it was in one of your slides, it
talked about kind of manipulation opportunities with Wilson
solution, and Wilson when you were talking, I kept thinking
and I am trying to think in my mind, what's the transition
between debt holders and equity holders because you are
probably aren't going to have a transition. And I think
there is something that's important about both of these,
there is friction in each one. There is also a lot of
friction in what you are proposing I think probably more.
Could the two of you just comment on that friction concept
more?
I think our position is yet, we don't see what these
frictions are, in terms of true economic costs. Again there
are private issues here that a lot of people in this room
focus on but remove those and think about what the true
social costs are and those aren't salient. I think our
reservation about any system that requires some individual
with some discretion in a position of distress to pull some
triggers, that's something that makes you wonder why haven't
you done that, why not just have that as equity in the first
place, that in particular applies to the cocos. So it may be
good to have a lot of equity and then in addition have bail-
in, but again if you are having liabilities out there that
are going to provide that bail-in there is still the
question, what are they serving, why can't they be equity. I
think it's a good question. And they are not cheaper. That's
the point they are not cheaper, there is the illusion of
them being cheaper because you say I am only paying 6% on
this and my equity is costing me 15% but we know that that's
going to be correct.
Yeah, what let me do the friction just to clarify is,
probably when you put up the thing about the reach to 30%, I
didn't know fair amount about that market and how it got the
way it is, and I think as far as functionally analysts look
at things. And I think analysts have a way of looking at
things today, both on the sell side and buy side and the
business is making that transition is the friction I think
that's associated with your kind of concept. Now the
friction in Wilson's is quite different, it's literally a
movement in money between a class of owners that won't be
able to continue holding something because their own capital
requirements will go up. So you have to move the money over
to a different set of buyers. And so I just wanted to hear
about how that would work and particularly also, I didn't
understand Wilson to have a notion of a trigger that had to
pulled, it just happens. Yes.
[Audience]
We didn't get into the exact issues of triggers. There has
been a lot of discussions. I think the easiest one for me is
one of the banks is either critically undercapitalized or
critically illiquid. And that can be in a bailing system
late, it can be on even Friday when they tell you we can't
settle trades on Monday. That does not require a lot of
discretion that requires knowledge of the fact of deep
illiquidity. In a lot of the systems we use with the FDIC,
we can move a little bit earlier than that. So there are
triggers that sometimes happen in advance of that, but it
still should be a very laid in the game debt like event. But
that happens already with respect to FDIC institutions. And
I think the bond market is kind of comfortable saying this
is what default consultancy means for a bank. You could move
that further back if you didn't have FDIC funds at-risk to
something where you couldn't fund on Monday. To answer your
more general question, at least as I see it I am not an
economist like the few people up here. The transition from
where we are to a bailing system relies on the capital
structured banking as it largely exists today. I think that
makes things a lot simpler. I think there will be
transitional cost but I think they are much easier to
manage. Some increase in debt cost. But I think that's a
reasonable price worth paying to get too big to fail out. I
think some of the cost proposed in this system would be
potentially much larger. I know that I know you disagree
with me on that.
Question: I want you to tell me the cost of withholding
equity path that nobody has been able to give me the cost.
I can give you one example. When we issued our cocos, which
have to turn in equity on either a capital trigger a failure
trigger or government assistance trigger so in any one at
the bad states where they have to become equity. So they are
not in anyway protected by the state. Issuing that debt
raised the value of our equity by about 10% over the course
of that next week relative to people saying I thought
creditors might have to attain all of this equity over the
next period, that this was something that the market seemed
to value this package of instruments better than just raw
equity.
Well your triggers that we need to discuss this later, but
the fact of the matter is that if the total risk is worn by
the balance sheet, then we have fundamental insight that the
risk cannot be held by somebody else. And therefore the
overall cost cannot change, that's a physical reality of
this. And this is like a gravitating force. In terms of
triggers, I think the one of the frictions is captured by
the statement that was ruled in a recent paper by an author
that actually was invited to be here today but couldn't,
that shows that there is extremely if there is a knife-edge
case, where if you have a price trigger, price equity
trigger, there even exists sort of a way, rational way to
price these things because there could be situations where
if you didn't have the trigger and the conversion ratio just
right, there would either be a situation where if you assume
that it converts to dozen and that sort of multiple
[inaudible] all kinds of things like that.
The trigger based on book values is not clearly going to
prevent a crisis. And so we would debate, today and tomorrow
about these triggers. Our point potentially, our point
completely is that we have not being given a reason by Erwin
or anybody that whatever he was going to issue as cocos
should not be equity. Just because you can actually sell
something does not prove anything, because you can sell any
security out there. My final question about cocos is, if
they are so good, why don't firms just issue them of course
in the high-seed economy, in other words they are not
illegal to issue. There are lots of things that can be
issued. If they do something, like get tax benefits and
remove and reduce bankruptcy cost, why don't we see cocos
issued in the rest of the economy. Here they are issued
because they have Swiss capital requirements allow half of
the capital requirements to be satisfied this way. So there
instead of equity they are issued but why aren't they issued
with the rest of the market?
The rest of the market use Chapter 11.
[Audience]
But having spent sometime with leverage finance people, you
get very coco like effects. With regular debt structures and
industrial corporations you don't get that for financials.
So we have a lot of this automatic equitization in a normal
industrial company that doesn't happen naturally for banks.
So we would do something different.
Because the banks don't want to, but I am saying that they
will feel differently about it if regulators make them and
if they are already highly -
Question: So first to comment, it's interesting I guess that
I noticed sort of two themes in the discussion. One is the
externalities of bank failure are huge. And so they are huge
imperfections in the asset market which arise when banks
fail. At the same time you have more
[inaudible] requires very, very good capital markets and
very wise investors, to perfectly see through that the risk
of their holdings has fallen in a certain way. So it's
interesting to me you have both of those concepts going at
the same time, just a comment. I guess my second question is
this, why didn't the banking sector work better in the
1800s. Capital was 30%, 40%. It was in the UK it was in the
US. People still made lots of bad decisions, I think there
were still railroad bubbles, canal bubbles, this or that
etc. You had lots of economic history written on this period
and thus sort of bad -- of banking why did that happen.
I am actually not a historian of banks, I barely know
anything about banks. But I am asking my questions and I
still didn't give him any answers so I know enough to ask
good questions from the year and half I am looking at it.
But the history of bank I don't like to know, but I can say
the following. These banks were not publicly held, the
access to equity could have been, they didn't have
diversification opportunities like banks today have. The
world is different. The question is why can't the world be
the same on the total capitalization, that's the question,
it's because our banks right now why not. So we can go back
in history and ask these questions and we can come up with
all kinds of reasons that might or might not have to do with
where we are right now. But what we are asking is right now
for the banking system, they we have right now and given the
crisis that we had just recently, why can't we, what is the
impediment for banks to stopping dividends and equity
payouts and raise some right offerings and other things and
capitalize themselves over the next five years, six years to
level that seem crisis but may be or not.
[Audience]
Actually the last 10 minutes or so even though we are over
with them, I viewed as actually quite memorable. And I would
invest it for anything. I want to thank everybody, the
speakers, the participants, the clearing house, Paul for a
wonderful day. And I learned a lot and I hope you get to do
this again. Thank you for coming.
[Applause]